in a relationship yeah how long oh
you've been married five years oh you
got any advice for I'm bout to get
married so tell me advice cuz I'm here
you know
[Music]
he's getting another [ __ ] they gave
me telling you man do any black dog is
brain I come over smooth sometimes it's
the best as we had to learn you gotta
learn to be independent cuz it's just
otherwise it's too much men is your wife
here you gotta beat down so much you
can't even add that much you worried you
gonna be looking does I realize this -
there's like a like here's the thing I'm
gonna be completely honest the happiest
rows of my life are with my fiance I'm
not gonna act like that's not true right
Dan 10th peak happiness get that right
and then the rest of the relationship is
like a four and a half you know one is
like you guys never done interval
training at the gym best happiness in a
relationship is a lot like yeah you know
I remember a bicep she had a Bed Bath
and Beyond
oh this dogs been around rest of my life
with oh we gotta go return the shoe we
bought a Bed Bath and Beyond
[Applause]
and I realized she also made sure I can
never be as happy as I can with her
because any time I start to have too
much fun with somebody else she trying
to cook it up
I don't even drink a party my online
gold hang out my friends are like a
diner all night New York City and then I
like 1:32 I'll always get a text from
her and no matter what she says I can
tell the subtext is you would havin fun
for about 32 too many minutes I know
this is one real fun starts oh I need
you bring your ass home and cuddle with
me till I fall asleep and then you don't
get to sleep all night and then I
pretend I'm worried about that [ __ ] in
the morning I have a horrible I've
always had sleeping problems and now is
worse than ever and my girl stays
pretending she gives a [ __ ] and it's
like no you don't he's like no baby I
feel so bad I feel like all you need is
darkness and I'm like [ __ ] you got a
nightlight what do you think I might get
the darkness it's very easy to do quick
that's all it takes
quick is over and darkness down but she
says getting worried that somebody's
gonna intrude into the house okay if
somebody does you think I'm gonna be
able to do something you're chose me
this is your mistake
listen if most of the breaks into our
house be under attack and that's what
we just underneath it all right tank is
gonna be on top of us and you can find a
way out what do you think I'm gonna go
with the light hey who goes there the
light is really just gonna let him see
how small I am be quiet when I'm broken
I got a does not a lot of time actually
kill you in a couple seconds I'm too
small they even buy her real time I got
gladly die for my girl but it would
happen so quick that he was still good
to her leg